منوع ايضا للعاج وسائل اعلام كرديه سوريه
ارتفاع عدد
القتلى جراء الضربات الجويه على شرقي
سوريا الى سته بينهم ثلاثه عراقيين واذهب
الى عامر لافي في بغداد
عامر مع مثل هذا الحديث من قبل وسائل
اعلام كرديه سوريه عن سته قتلى بينهم
ثلاثه عراقيين اي ما الذي ما هو المتوقع
في بغداد وما الذي يقال حول هذا الاستعداد
ايضا في العراق خاصه بانه ساحه من هذه
الساحات التي من المحتمل ان تشملها
الضربات نعم سلمى العراقيون هنا ينظرون
الى هذا الرد الامريكي على انهم هم ربما
الهدف الابرز لهذه الضربات الاعتبار كما
ذكرنا بان القتلى الامريكيين الثلاثه هم
وفقا للتصريحات الامريكيه كانوا بسبب ضربه
نفذتها فصائل عراقيه من المقاومه وبالتالي
يعتقدون بان العراق سيكون ربما او تنفيذ
هذه الضربات سيكون بشكل اكبر في داخل
العراق وبالتالي الوضع هنا او اذا رسمنا
صوره للوضع الان في العراق فيمكننا القول
بان الانتظار والترقب والاستعداد هو سيد
الموقف بالحديث من مصادر في فصائل
المقاومه العراقيه تحدثت عن استعداد كبير
عن اخلاء للكثير من المواقع تحسبا لهذه
الضربات وعن استعداد للرد على اي ضربه
امريكيه ستوجه الى مقراتهم والى افراده
وكثير من منصاتهم بدات ترسل رسائل تحذيريه
وتطمين في نفس الوقت او تهديديه ان صح
وصفها تقول بان هي جاهزه وانها ستدافع حتى
الرمق الاخير عن مجاهديها وعن ارضها وتقول
ايضا بانها اذا ما استهدفت فانها ستقلب
الطاوله وستقل الموازين وسيستمر الرد
وبالتالي هناك حاله كما ذكرنا من استعداد
استعداد الكبير لهذه الضربه وحتى ان
الفصائل كما تعلمين هناك حزب الله العراقي
الذي كان قد اعلن انه علق عملياته
العسكريه قبل عده ايام لكنه للاشاره قال
بان المقاومه السلبيه كما وصفها ستبقى
مستمره والمقصود هنا بالمقاومه السلبيه اي
الرد على اي استهداف ل مقراته او لافراده
وبالتالي اي ضربه امريكيه ستجعل من كل
الفصائل العراقيه سواء التي اعلنت بانها
ستو او ستعلق عملياتها او التي اعلنت ايضا
بانها ستستمر في تنفيذ هذه العمليات حتى
توقف الحرب على غزه كلها سيرد على هذا
القصف الامريكي وبالتالي كثير من
المراقبين هنا يقولون ويعتقدون بان اي
ضربه امريكيه على العراق على العكس مما
ارادته الولايات المتحده اي ايقاف وارسال
رسائل تحذيريه وحمايه مقراتها ومواقعها
وقواعدها على العكس من ذلك سيكون الرد هو
الذي ستحظى به هذه القواعد وستؤدي الموقف
وسيبدا كثير من هذه الفصائل بضرب القواعد
الامريكيه بالنسبه للمعلومات سلمى وصلنا
قبل قليل بان هناك انفجارات في منطقه
القائم على الحدود مع سوريا لكن ليس هناك
تاكيد رسمي ولا تاكيد من من مصادرنا في
المقاومه العراقيه لكن نحاول التاكد من
هذه المعلومه اي انه السؤال هنا الكبير هل
بدا بالفعل القصف في داخل العراق نذكر
طبعا بان القائمه استهدفت قبل ذلك في ال
24 من الشهر الماضي استهدفها الطيران
الامريكي وايضا في نفس الوقت الذي استهدف
فيها مقرات في جنوب بغداد وتحديدا في
محافظه بابل الى الجنوب من بغداد حوالي 60
م و نتج عن هذا القصف الامريكي يومها في
ال4 من الشهر الماضي عدد من القتلى
والجرحى من صفوف الحشد الشعبي والحشد
الشعبي كما تعلمين هو جزء من القوات
المسلحه العراقيه وه هذا ما استدعى في
اليوم التالي بيانات استنكار وتنديد من
الحكومه العراقيه على اعتبار ان قوات
التحالف القوات الامريكيه استهدفت جزء من
القياده من العسكريه من الجيش العراقي
قياده او او جنود وكتائب تابعين ل تحديدا
ومباشره لرئيس الوزراء وان هذا انتهاك
صارخ للسياده العراقيه اقول هذا طبعا من
باب التذكير لما جرى في يومها وهو حقيقه
سلمى ما جرى بعد كل قصف
طال المقرات الحشد الشعبي هنا في داخل
العراق الامر الاخر والذي يتحدث عنه
كثيرون هنا وتحديدا طبعا مصادر مقاومه انه
في الايام الماضيه الكثير من الطائرات بلا
طيار الامريكيه رصدت في اجواء العراق وقرئ
هذا التحرك الكبير لهذه الطائرات على انها
تحاول العثور على اهداف يمكن ضربها كاه
انتقاميه في المرحله القادمه